échauffement pour la compagnie nationale
de sécurité avant de rejoindre les rues
de bangui particulièrement instable de
ces dernières semaines avec son équipe
le colonel simon compte ramener le calme
dans les quartiers de la capitale
centrafricaine
je pense que avec le temps si tout va
bien avec le nos partenaires à nos
partenaires financiers et que une fois
que nous allons aller matériel approprié
nous serons dans les seize professeurs
de la république centrafricaine et avec
toute la population certificat la veille
le quartier pk 5 s'est réveillée sous
tension et des militaires et gendarmes
armes à la main étaient déployés dans
les rues dans la nuit un milicien
avaient ouvert le feu sur les forces de
l'ordre
l'affrontement a fait un mort et un
blessé selon les informations du
gouvernement dans le quartier pk 5 les
combat par arme à feu sont devenus
réguliers et inquiète les habitants dans
l'est dans les partis là-bas ya des
enfants il ya des moments qui sont en
déroute quoi sans tain de fluo par
rapport à ce qu'ils ont entendus et des
civils qui abandonnent leur logement
pour éviter les attaques en tout 240
mille personnes se seraient déplacées
dans le pays depuis la mi-décembre selon
amnesty international
fin 2020 six groupes armés réunis sous
le nom de la coalition des patriotes
pour le changement
la cpc défavorable à l'organisation des
élections présidentielle et législatives
ont mené des raids armés et occupé
plusieurs villes malgré la reprise de
plusieurs localités par l'armée
nationale soutenues par les casques
bleus et des troupes étrangères
la cpc poursuit ses attaques mi février
quatorze personnes ont perdu la vie dans
un site religieux de la ville de bambari
victimes des échanges de tirs entre les
forces pro gouvernementales et la cpc
des combats qui perdurent à la proche du
second tour des élections législatives
prévues le 16 mars prochain une date
plus que jamais incertaine